oddio tra cui anche all'ultimo internato
in toni testori coggi
speciale halloween iniziano gli spezzati
halloween in anticipo che mi sta bene se
vi piace avuto io adoro
ansa win oggi faremo un po pippo
marchioro aulin allora dentro ogni
palloncino ci sono ingredienti horror ma
al vino appunto ft dottore palloncini
fronte matri ma anche di green it clean
questo corpo di quindi questa volta non
vincerà chiaro più bello ma vincerà
chiaro sligo più horror e inquietante
tutto no più horror a dover più the
mother wind e sarete voi a deciderlo
perché alla fine del video metterò il
sondaggio qua in cui potrete votare
servetto io abbia vinto vitale quindi
mira cosa però che il video fino alla
fine fate il tipo
oggi in blu enrico rosso per chi votate
lasciate un bene anche se volete vedere
altri speciali halloween se questo video
raggiunge di spina letto andremo a fare
lo stesso di breeding giornalmente
linguanti quindi mettetevi con i pod da
fini e pop corn e iniziamo subito con le
nostre band che abbiamo letto molti
commenti avete detto che allevi talebana
perché sarebbe sorgere il sole dita
bertaggia non vedo bene all'inizio la
siano quattro pensa occhiali in zone
anche un livello così in uno studente ma
mettiamo la nostra aperta a tutti e
girato gira all'estero di claudio quadro
[Musica]
dai dai
il primo che volendo lasciamo prione
string questo no ma si somma aspetta che
all'inizio ma credo o che cosa
bianco
abbiamo già la corda ma dentro la
collana parente questi si vedranno bene
tutte le cose allora in intertoto ping
ha cominciato a colorado per agire cosa
non si dirà quale sceglie ottimo la mia
bisogno
guardate si vede sandro me io non ha
fatto dire da solo girato da anni non è
vero per niente non so se riuscite a
vedere il marito di un verde attraverso
non ci posso credere verde perché si di
sforzo
paura ad ettaro in uno strato dello
statuto
chicca 96 paura aiuto
ma non questo viaggio piatto o mio
portone sta facendo qualcosa di verde
cosa mi sembra un problema
ok ok decisamente è verde me c'è un
mostro schifoso dentro il nome del e che
è rimasto incollato sarà guerra schietti
e voce vedere che cosa si tocca
ovviamente il verde cioè al primo turno
la maledizione del verde guardate questo
mostro se lo schiacci schiacciarlo
comunque gli esseri occhio di fuori
no non ci riesco adesso però una volta
che lo slam sarà attivo ve lo farò
vedere meglio quindi secondo voi con e
più oso finora dopo proprio dalla colla
la strada è un tavolone adesso sì bello
ti aspetti
[Musica]
perché tutto questo è l'ostacolo sta che
tutti ok non venne eletto del city ha
detto perché non si vede dai contiamo
nella top 100 grosso dentro taglia
proprio dovere farlo studiare o falsi
una cosa ci hanno detto una cosa
stranissima addio sembra un mostro che
sta cercando di strumenti si estraggono
[Musica]
io penso che fino alla vecchiaia
scrive vi aspetta dopo giocava tutto qua
rischiamo una zucchetta qua dentro ci
sono due occhi di vedere ora guardate un
po cosa secco ha dentro cosa è uscito no
così bene sono occhi anno non di
serpente sono di vampiro
[Musica]
sono occhi di mostro
e ce n'è anche un altro che è uguale
rosso per quello di miso marroncino
nemmeno questo mostro esatto quindi
quale fa più schifo finora e fanno paura
i moti ovvero il sangue trasmette tutto
rosso sangue meglio di verde ma va bene
ma ogni istante ma che forse mi fate
schifo petto e più a questo secondo me
ancora ok ma cos'è manzù papercut notano
un'ora piano per primo la paura proprio
questo che non so se si vede in camera
sanguinosa
altro sangue fallo su piazzetta frazioni
[Musica]
viene dimenticata cosa cerca pace sangue
mischiato giochi tutto sembra stanco con
pezzettini di carta li mettiamo tutti
sullo stesso punto che sono dicono che
emettono quelli là davanti in mente
allora abbiamo reso una doppietta
k nostro pianeta proprio must ascoltato
[Musica]
tacco di ritardo è assassina di zucca no
vabbè trattando il quasi sono i vermi
mercati nei fatti un po ora c'è un mix
tra verde rosso spero che diventi più
rosso ma guardate qua che mischia volo
speriamo che vada via in verde
qui a tema halloween stanno uscendo le
bolle faccia troppo quindi finora porta
più schifo il mio dio di halloween agli
occhi il mostro ei bermi spettacolo
mischia si vede successi tango lasciato
che si era formato 80 come si dovrà
netti verdi dell'altro sangue e ancora
più rosso sangue fa paura chimico
mercati o fiori aspetta è mister berruto
aspetta aspetta
[Musica]
vai preso si apprende il fantasma di
ricordato d'allocco c concluso detto
scheletro addio certo la
inquietantissimo tra l'altro etico perde
un colore dorato proprio
[Musica]
e io non devo in pescare bendata perché
mi è rimasto solo uno
[Musica]
no nessuno questo mi piace la musica che
cos'è pacifiche fatto c'è qualcosa
dentro che questa schiuma da barba ma se
qualcosa di grosso dentro no ho capito
quale un occhio
vediamo un po a tre occhi quindi anche
se è vero piena di occhi guardarsi un
occhio venoso dentro dire che era il mio
volte inquietante mischia vola e
stranamente nessuno nessuno di prato il
color verde stranamente bisogna però poi
dopo moto oddio e mi sembra che abbia
due occhi uno diverso dall'altro poi gli
altri non so dove sono finiti nei vermi
fortunatamente non si vedono molto
adesso stanno mangiando
vediamo il tumore o inquietantissimo con
quello scheletro non stai dentro si
mischia ci troviamo bene con quello
slide hampton zio varrebbe su cosa paura
che su che altro con i ragni
oddio come si fa ad attivare questo
[Musica]
finora quale pensate che sia più
inquietante poi no molto attivo sarà
anche diverse dobbiamo vedere
comunque il mio sito parecchio paura dei
ragni scheletro pentacolo e melma verde
ok ora andiamo ad attivare il vostro
super naviga e poi vi ripeto con vedere
bene uno ad uno conti potrete votare per
quanto è ora quanto è halloween è per
ispo niente mr mandato io ho già la mia
fan page che vadano mentre vitale da
allora ragazzi ecco qua drive qua potete
vedere l'occhio e qua ce lo scrissi che
vi faccio vedere guardate un po qua c'è
in realtà riusciva questo coso guardate
però è scappato via
beh allora riempiamo quanto di prime sei
ora il mostriciattolo perde slime
dall'occhio e ci è rimasta questa mini
stress ball molto carina e che ha
qualcosa dentro un liquido
penso comunque lo slime guardate così
anche mucchio di mostro una succosa i
verdi come qualche parte da trend è
diventato rosa purtroppo non è un colore
molto da halloween
però non so come si è trasformato in uno
slam super rosa che cosa abbiamo alla
pallina vediamo ecco il verme
guardate qua mi dissi mo e ora mi faccio
sentire i suoni smr vitale sta trattando
in pochi e c'è un commento di ieri il
video di ieri che diceva vitale lo fa
apposta frase cosi normale dice no no io
proprio non l'ho mai visto penso che
restate l'esperto bravo indici quindi
queste news live da teli un voto da 1 a
10 per aspetto halloween e per sony smr
vediamo ora quello di vitale del mio
smile allora innanzitutto sono contento
del colore di questo slime se c'è un po
di cose all'interno non lo portiamo già
dal dal ragnetto che si può vedere qui
1 2 e 3 ragnetti inclusi in cui ci
abbiamo uno scheletro qui è il tentacolo
né io mi piace molto perché un po o
trasparente col colore rosso sangue
tipico del dialogo in tipic deal e si e
poi questi ragnetti sono problemi alla
schiena sono profilati questo per
elastico adesso andiamo a vedere il
rumore insieme poco scoppiettante e
adesso proviamo a fare il po king
vediamo se poi avevo dimenticato ma
c'era anche il lo slime con nicolò color
petrolio incluso potendo che è stato
assorbito pensiero da questo slime
malefico è ormai non si vede più il
colore il colore scuro perché tutto
rosso fi
ok andiamo di pochi non funziona errore
404 il proprio no non fa da fiore così
comunque può king non c'è però dai non
c'è il file stile halloween si sono
proprio più inquinante eh si questo blog
sembra bunga bideau e trasparenza ok
allora ditemi che ne pensate votate devo
darne permettere caratteri allora il
sondaggio su cui potete votare se ho
vinto io sì ha vinto vitale in base
appunto in questa però la quanto era lui
[Applauso]
a cantare un palla più della zucca cosa
[Musica]
c'è a chi piace chi lo rivedrà da lui
tante figure dei commenti quali altri
video di halloween progetti che facciamo
le migliori idee rimetterò un coratino e
andremo a farle e ora non ci lasciamo un
pò 4 cliccare per veder le nostre
attrezzate just mx line i nostri video
divertenti che cazzo quella che
preferite e buona visione
ciao